I want you to think about how you know
multiplication works when you're working
with complex numbers and remember
complex numbers that's all these vectors
are so for example if I wanted to do P
times Q P times Q think back to when we
did this if I had some complex number
like this and some other complex number
like this when we multiply these two
together call them 7w right or P and Q
what do you do with the moduli at the
front you multiply the moduli those are
a convenient why do you know is that so
to make this we want an illustration
that quite clearly demonstrates what's
going on okay so just for the sake of
convenience I've got this guy here and
I'm going to say well let's just let its
length just as an example it's just an
illustration let its length be two units
okay suppose it's modulus it's r2 was
two units okay so if this guy here was
two then when I multiply P times Q how
would you describe the length of my new
product vector PQ don't you describe
it's gonna be well you're gonna take
whatever this magis was I don't define
what that is who knows what it is and
I'm going to multiply it by in this case
two so whatever my new vector is going
to be I just know it's going to be twice
as long as this vector does that make
sense because it will have double the
modulus because I multiply my two so far
so good now is the modulus what are the
arguments have these arguments interact
with each other you add arguments right
so what that comes round to you is is
your when you're adding these you're
rotating something around okay so if for
example this is inclined out well we
need an incline right so you're inclined
off from for horizontal same deal over
here whatever these angles are you're
going to add them together so it's kind
of rotating this guy further along by
whatever this angle is here okay
whatever that happens to be let's just
give it a name let's call it feel it's
nice and original so my new product
vector should be twice as long as this
one and should be kind of like this one
but rotated theta radians further does
that make sense okay so to help us
visualize this draw me another copy of
pitch just do another one over here
bismi now I'm going to draw a new vector
it's gonna be twice the length of pain
and it's been rotated around by this egg
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to draw a new one that's off by
will about that angle now to me that
looks something like yes
cool Athena let's course enough isn't it
I have a [ __ ] or anything like that
okay now my new vector I actually drew
an arrowhead prematurely my new vector
needs to be how much longer then paid
twice the length right so what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna keep on drawing
that's awful okay and just for the sake
of scale what I'm gonna put on there is
I'm gonna put another copy or two on
this vector and it's linked so you can
see right it's like look here's one of
pay and here's the second one
because this new this new vector I've
got is twice the length so it's wonder
this should be two of those strong
together can you know and see why I put
quite much around my P vector matter
what I do that
these share the same magnitude as my
original vector feed but they don't
share the same direction so they're not
actually equal but it's just so you can
see the scale and see what's going okay
all right yeah
simple idea simple idea but it unlost so
much cool stuff okay just before I do
that I want to show you where multiply
right comen number is coming the context
numbers that you multiply by ah maybe
I'll put it yeah I am negative 1 now
you've already done negative 1 right we
did over here when we're doing
subtraction you take a vector you
multiply it by the vector that's called
negative 1 think about it what's going
to happen to the magnitude when you
multiply by negative 1
think about it stay the same because the
magnitude effect up is 1 what's going to
happen into the direction it's going to
you can the other two inch the time
they're gonna flip you know cuz it turns
around the opposite direction that's
what this is or a better way of thinking
about it is you're rotating around pi
radians okay so for example if I
multiply this by negative 1 it's gonna
rotate around pi radians
what am i that's the other most common
thing you're going multiply life it's
almost the same right magnitude stays
the same but directions you're not gonna
retain around pi radians you're only
gonna retain around pi on 2 radians
because that's where I is right eye is
just this vertical one does that make
sense so if I multiply this guy by I in
fact you could all write it up here yeah
we can just fit it I reckon
Chuck a right angle in there that's P
times I right it's just being rotated at
90 degrees you can rotate it at space
absolutely